hey guys what's up I'm a lot of a Charl
amazon welcome to my channel this is my
second battlefield hardline multiplayer
video this time we are playing blood
money enjoy ok so get a little bit of
time that looks good yeah let's go with
that so I'm playing is the operator
which is what I've been playing as a lot
today because it's kind of good for like
mid to ranged especially in this
gameplay mode which is so much stuff so
much stuff let's give that yeah sure
yeah so blood money is basically that
you have to go to an area collect some
money and take it back to your base and
the COTS will be doing the same thing
because obviously that's what cops like
to do a nurse / time but you also have
the option to right that bass and I've
actually been having a lot of fun with
this one um it's one of the most
exciting but thought that I would start
off recording here by letting you guys
see I guess on the customization options
and stuff I was wondering what that does
the mosque just makes you look cool
barely the revived is definitely very
handy find my carbon knife I like that
one where is it yeah machete that's cool
oh alright I think we're ready to jump
on in
let's go the cybercriminals and it's
pretty standard stuff go steal the money
the police are also trying to get it so
tense really a kick in the meetup area
which is why the money pile is is where
it gets really really full-on but unlike
my other videos that I have a couple
years so for so far this one is yeah I
can have a lot of combats i thought i
would specifically shoes blood money for
my next video because of that but now
i'm still cautious about it like we're
just running there like an idiot like I
don't know I feel like a lot of people
play these games like they're Rambo like
what are you doing that's not how you
succeed at things but that said I'm
pretty terrible if s doesn't she just
generally they're not one of my strong
points so what do I do alright so here's
the money pile that's one of my boys
currently doing alright so let's just
steal a bunch of it see you out of ten
yet I don't try to take much more than
that early on he needs game so as you
can see i don't know if you can see a
bottom right 2 out of 10 yeah I've been
trying not to take too much all at once
because if the other team kills you they
can steal it so I just do it bit by bit
at the start and then towards the end
kind of crammed in more if my team is
doing well and it's not too much of a
risk to give them 10 million or whatever
cuz i'm pretty sure it's saying true
million of 10 but i can possibly carry
which is ridiculous but unfortunately
the more you collect you don't actually
get heavier like i would love it if the
more money you had you kind of got
weighed down so that it meant more of a
choice face thing um so I haven't seen
anyone just yet jumping rattle in milk
sweet
all right let's go yeah seed enemy volts
over there really will write it though
maybe later maybe some other time for
right now I'm all good just keep on
running try to avoid again and shut up
can't even see anyone it's kind of nice
you know being at all someone's dead in
there so that's probably going to be
someone in here maybe I'm sorry oh [ __ ]
Mary's doing I'm good that was quick
success okay you know one of my boys all
right you see promotes you got him you
gonna feel good yeah only got 19 yeah I
do come in oh look at him three oh no no
no se lo Zulu okay fine fine i think i
want to get out of here it's the heat
man you're everywhere run oh [ __ ] oh my
god nearly just go right over uh I
should have looked out for that okay are
you ready to leave I really got one it's
not gonna be a huge problem if I die
dude obviously don't want to smell
looking go there we got all that us okay
it's our little too
make it out of here okay no no no I made
it this fall i think i've done' right I
like my chances right now should be all
good yep run on back to face drop the
money off to do so this one in that it's
like a bigger map is kind of more like
you know feels like a regular
battlefield game most of them though
some of the other mode story although
the most of us people do I guess but
it's still not like a free-for-all death
match kind of thing you know you still
have an objective still play as two
sides of both have different dialogue
and I'm playing as the criminals yeah oh
no oh no no no damn it Jesus that was
quick I got me in the head every they
should have been more careful there
goddammit son of [ __ ] all right three
two one let's deploy get red back in
there already defend the vault really no
I think we want to put my money in the
vault whip defending it it's fun how
about is doing just fine
I do a bit of catching up to today but I
you know I think I think I'm pretty
confident I've won most of these that i
played so far but maybe I should stop
grabbing a little bit more money house
it's gonna get me isn't he I'm gonna
regret missing that dude ready to go
how'd you go buddy where do you go dick
come on push it up and smarter about
that
he's gonna be riding in somewhere I
think go inside the building me okay
guys sounds like Coltrane you boobie
whoa all right I think maybe someone
else took care of that guy everything's
okay let's grab some tea ish is some
quiche man yeah I'm gonna grab some all
this time around yes yes we are so it
seems all right let's run on out of here
cuz seems pretty clear maybe trying to
point around this way a little bit just
to stay out of it because they usually
come from the left side because that's
what I bolt is obviously so she's okay
clear run again but yeah sometimes they
do like common trend still fear ult and
well that's not happening it just gets
so hectic you I think should we don't
steal from there's like what do we what
do we do someone seems near us otherwise
they wouldn't be shooting that helps
that was good even it up even dust out
on it'll be it all right Blood Money
coin cool thanks me in sweet just keep
do you have a book right now that I
can't walk but i'm just gonna maybe do a
later i'm just gonna run it again no one
here like it's might be what coming and
going at different times cuz they
obviously have a lot of cash to like
obviously they speak to a lot of time
here we hadn't it there anyone in here
no i'm stuck my friends dead someone's
surely oh [ __ ] kool she was there the
one place i didn't freaking a look of
course he was that was smart let's good
move your dick but i respect you
policeman already let's jump in there
taking our money oh no right again you
mean but they are also taking the money
that is not ours that we are trying to
steal goddamn criminals in their lack of
logic ethics goddamn unethical criminals
I like me some ethical criminals much
prefer thank you that restored run again
oh jeez no it's not okay bolts big hit
there a tower bolts is that what he's
saying all right all right well I'm
gonna take a bunch of cash remember
Carrie they're hitting a vault they are
Jesus
there's no point running back when were
you just take a bunch go kill them lay
them all out you need to come to him
okay I'm getting like just like five
million bucks here I think it is at
least i'm pretty sure about for teens oh
my god I know what are you here to go
fault cuz you didn't tell me good I
could figure it out it's written on my
screen but I don't know he just runs
does that mean they stopped cuz it still
says the same radio definitely being
shut up I know oh my god maybe I should
go into the back honey Hannah me chef
dude okay seems all right seems okay
jeez who you know God ah nice am Ilona
nice aim Oh think he's my house okay I
don't even know what happened to sign
they just don't panic I'll see I dropped
all my money and we just put it right
back I think yeah looked up better for
us than them I think why did you disturb
Renee tattos dick was a cool I feel like
that was very undeserved didn't ask for
this hey well he was dealt with back we
go no one's yelling about it anymore I
have forgot I had that very extra
magazine thank you I think boss climb is
really necessary when I don't it too
much climbing attend to just move sorted
in between buildings and avoid them
anyway so whatever who gives a 4k she
says climbing over something
me too far away we're gonna come in hey
there maybe I should come on buddy come
through this door daya see you coming
see you come on come at me yeah that's
what I thought that's what I thought hey
where's this other guy be good shooting
him in the legs glib dogs above you what
his abs that a helicopter outside or
something that's whatever that is plowed
think I'm a bird I'm all good not gonna
fall for that stick is [ __ ] all
right we sweet let's go now i'm doing
that scum oh my god you're such a dick I
don't know who that is but i am not a
fan the guy's route i'm grabbing you
money so much money i think i might even
go maybe a beautiful time you know what
got it full 10 that's how much I care
about your advice mr. brood man just
doing it anyway all right let's go
oh my god what oh my god I got run over
by myself okay i forgot that I did that
Jesus Christ no no uh-uh of course that
was gonna happen Jesus that was not not
great you know I'm not overly pleased
with what went down there doo doo doo
it's just um like cash to spend I don't
know pretty happy with everything I'm
not really needing vehicles at the
moment to be honest just jump back in
stilly yeah I shot that fall see how
much I helped look that pole would have
been pristine without me oh [ __ ] the
back here again come on come at me come
at me good time to ring would Jesus all
right it was fine you know to shut my
friend in the head are they any more new
you all right Whitney Lee one we're like
pretty much flying right now no good I
think you know everything's coming up
milhouse everything's coming up milhouse
just take a little bit more take it back
and I'm pretty sure we will have won the
game cuz yeah we got that cash oh we got
so many funds through Rudy reach walking
home all right that's good it's good
it's good it's conflict in here I think
I can hear it grabbed a drop bunny three
of us will be fine oh we've heard the
grenade when did not even come from
someone downstairs
everything alone this guy's down well
good yeah cut him down okay we're fine
we're fine never lose all right
everything is awesome everything is cool
infertility 1 mil 230 feel like maybe
when we get back this time you will look
what I think but I don't want to take
too much and [ __ ] up the earth so let's
jump on this roof only had a little bit
obviously very good landing on my behalf
cool well nice try good work mobile so I
guess this does get repetitive but for
some reason every time it's fun like I
don't get pulled us at all because you
never know who's gonna be there you
never know if the enemy is gonna be
there you don't know whether gonna be
you don't know if you're gonna get back
to their vaults they're gonna be there
like it's not while you're running
between the same places ever ever again
it really doesn't feel T so I just
really really enjoyed this game mode i
really like know what to expect as part
of that I guess one I want it for us you
guys 63 not great could've done better
but you know not horrible either so
that's uh that's blood money good stuff